as the midnight moon rises on black  wings  we await the light at the end  in life and in death glory to mother  [Music]  miranda  but you're whining we're almost there  rose where are you  hello if there are any survivors out  there come to my  to louisa's house near the fields  oh no they're coming who is  what the hell was that  stop shouting you'll draw the monsters  tell me what is going on around here it  doesn't make any sense  mother miranda has always protected us  you escaped  my little brother's idiot games did you  [Music]  let's see how special you are  is this all that's left from your entire  village all that's  left there is no one left  [Music]  [Applause]  and now that the games begin  there is no safe every sorry bastard out  there has been ripped in a hack  tomorrow we're all be dead no let me go  chris what the hell  i gotta say i'm surprised you made it  this far it'd be a shame if something  happened to you now  you killed mia now do me and finish the  job  you